on vient d'entendre vladimir poutine et
michail michaud style mais on n'a pas
véritablement entendu de non est ce que
vous avez des informations du côté de
moscou concernant la composition de ce
nouveau gouvernement
bonjour effectivement des images des
premières images viennent d'apparaître
sur les chaînes fédérales russes
en revanche nous n'avons pas encore la
liste complète ce qu'il est possible de
dire en fonction des des images qui ont
été données c'est que healy a
manifestement à nouveau ministre pour
l'éducation nationale kravtsov qui est
un jeune technocrate néolibérale créé
très orienté sur le numérique ce qui
présage pas grand chose de beau en tout
cas pour la réforme de l'école dont le
niveau a déjà largement baissé un
problème également se pose avec le
ministre de l'économie qui a sauté on ne
regrettera pas beaucoup l'ancien
ministre d'économie à des skins qui
avaient fait de très faible prestation
devant la doublette disiez tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait a priori un
nouveau ministre de l'éducation un
néolibéral nommé kravtsov est ce qu'on
en sait plus sur les autres postes clés
notamment au ministère des affaires
étrangères quid de sérieux et lavrov ou
encore au ministère de la défense quel
avenir pour sergueï choïgou alors en ce
qui concerne le tube ou en tout cas il
est apparu sur les images le ministère
affaires étrangères n'attendait pas de
changement significatif mais nous
n'avons pas vu encore la preuve sur les
images sachant qu'il peut être en
déplacement
le nouveau un nouveau premier
premier ministre et est nommé il s'agit
de belloy search qui est un économiste
retrait renommée il remplace silouanov
qui était le ministre des finances est
également le premier ministre sait qui
en soi est plutôt un bon signe puisque
belooussoff toutes proportions gardées a
plutôt une inclination pour l'économie
réelle dans un gouvernement dont le bloc
gouvernementales sont très très orientée
vers l'économie numérique donc ça permet
un certain équilibre
un nouveau ministre de la culture aussi
je n'ai pas le nom mais en tous cas me
dicks qui a sauté et en économie aussi
d'un nouveau ministre qui est l'ancien
gouverneur de la région de perm lui
aussi particulièrement technocrates et
axée sur la nouvelle console en quelque
sorte globalement on peut dire pour
l'instant de ceux de ce gouvernement qui
le gardent la structure duale qui est
advenu traditionnelle en russie c'est à
dire du bloc des ministres à
présidentielle qui sont plus orientés
vers la protection de la souveraineté et
le bloc des ministres gouvernementaux le
bloc plus sociale économique culturelle
un sportif nouveau ministre du sport
aussi qui a lui et de tendance beaucoup
plus néolibérale est très axé sur le
numérique et le management
justement vous venez de parler
du nouveau ministre des sports en sait
que jusqu'à présent c'était pavel
kolobkov on sait que la russie pourrait
être exclue des prochains jeux
olympiques de tokyo
avec cette nouvelle nomination à quoi
faut-il s'attendre avec le tribunal
arbitral du sport qui va devoir trancher
prochainement
alors il est difficile de dieu si vous
voulez que l'arrivée d'un nouveau
ministre va pas dit calme en changer la
situation puisque la situation par
rapport à la russie est liée à la
politique générale menée par la russie
pas uniquement par les 10 c aux causes
des décisions prises par le ministre des
sports
donc ce qui peut jouer beaucoup plus
sain c'est le signal envoyé par la
réforme constitutionnelle qui est en
cours d'analysé qui lie à d'être déposé
aujourd'hui par le président la
fédération de russie à la douma la
chambre basse du parlement en russie qui
renforce largement la souveraineté du
pays et sans remettre en cause la
participation de la russie sur la scène
internationale ne veut pas que la russie
soit se dissolvent adam les un monde
globalisé ça c'est un signal fort qui
est envoyé c'est ce genre de signal qui
peut jouer sur l'ombre de décisions
notamment en matière d'un pic sans
oublier que concrètement ce qui concerne
la ferme à pic sur le plan juridique
la russie a de très très grande chance
de gagner devant le tribunal du sport
s'il juge endroits et nous en politique
kannberg au lof qu'aux émirats et demi
justine nouveau un chef du gouvernement
russe
dit tout à l'heure à vladimir poutine
qu'ils comptaient faire dès ce soir son
premier conseil des ministres à quelle
politique ce qu'il faut s'attendre
désormais le cap a été donné il s'agit
de la mise en oeuvre à renforcer des des
projets des projets présidentiels de la
non ce qui a été fait tant sur le plan
social que sur le plan économique
donc si vous voulez le cap et garder du
numérique numérisation de l'état est
devenu le pari fait sur l'économie
numérique ce qui éloigne la russie de
l'économie réelle
sachant que jusqu'à présent le ministre
d'ailleurs qui était responsable du
numérique
enfin la numérisation de l'économie a
sauté en raison de résultats absolument
déplorable
donc est-ce que justin qui lui a réussi
à intégrer le numérique dans le service
fiscal qui dirigeait avant parce qu'il
l'a fait c'est voler de manière
pragmatique il a utilisé ce qui était
utile dans la technologie sans tomber
dans le fantasme du culte qui est en
train de se mettre en place
s'il arrive à garder cet équilibre au
niveau du gouvernement
ça peut donner des résultats
intéressants
si l'on continue à tomber dans les
dérives où il faut de l'innovation où il
faut faire quelque chose
l'innovation pour l'innovation sens très
bien savoir ce que l'on doit faire
on arrive dans les délires de des
voitures volantes on est arrivés un peu
sur tintin sur la lune
je me permets de vous couper parce que
l'agencé ria novosti vient de publier
les noms des ministres du nouveau
gouvernement
donc sergueï lavrov est dont le nouveau
gouvernement donc ministre des affaires
étrangères il va rester à la tête de la
diplomatie russe également
sergueï choïgou qui reste ministre de la
défense selon l agence ria novosti ces
deux nominations ces deux postes clés
qui ne changent pas à l'échelon
international qu'est ce que ça va donner
quelles conséquences en vous ça c'est
très bien c'est la partie du bloc
présidentiel justement qui est en
quelque sorte la carcasse de l'état et
qui permet une stabilité dans la
politique de la russie la représentation
de la russie soit c'est internationale
mais également sur la stabilité
intérieure pour le pays donc ce sont
deux poids lourds se sont des ministres
qui font partie des plus anciens ni
sachant quand même que show blue est
entré en tout cas dès les années 90 dans
la politique gouvernementale c'est lui
qui a créé le ministère des situations
extraordinaires ensuite maintenant il
est à la défense
lavrov ya une quinzaine d'années
d'expérience au ministère des affaires
étrangères ce sont les poids lourds si
vous voulez qu'ils tiennent en quelque
sorte la carcasse de l'état en russie
indépendamment du président donc ça ce
sont d'excellentes nouvelles permet de
dire qu'il va y avoir une stabilité au
niveau de la politique internationale de
la russie que seule la politique anti
lié politique de paix me savais
étrangères mais également la politique
de défense puisque aujourd'hui la russie
est présente sur un certain nombre de
lieux de conflits pour tenter de
pacifier les situations que ce soit en
syrie que ce soit aussi on éprouvait
exil est là pour éviter justement
dégradation des situations
donc c'est un signal fort est largement
positif car notre goal of quoi encore
une réaction par rapport aux ministres
de l'est
conomie maxime fréchette nikov et
est-ce que vous allez plus
d'informations sur lui alors c'est lui
qui était l'ancien gouverneur jusqu'à
aujourd'hui de la région de perm
sachant que c'est justement à perm où il
y a eu un incident extrêmement grave
dans un hostel ou des jeunes personnes
des personnes notamment un enfant sont
décédés
c'est à partisans si vous voulez de la
dérégulation et de l'allemand
surveillance du retrait en quelque sorte
d'aidé en viennent de contrôle sur le
business qui salit pas simplement de lui
mais c'est une tendance à la mode qui a
provoqué de nombreux problèmes en russie
en matière de sécurité notamment pour
les consommateurs de ces lieux donc à
voir ce qu'il fera au niveau de
l'économie en général en russie on veut
pas dire que ce soit une personne
extrêmement forte
en tout cas comparer mans avait là où
sauf qu'ils le premier premier ministre
premiers 10 points ministre pardon c'est
c'est une personne quand même assez
faible à voir s'est il fait partie du
groupe des plus tôt des technocrates si
vous voulez de ce gouvernement qui n'ont
pas de carrure politique fédérale encore
particulièrement particulièrement pesé
merci beaucoup tiré une belle goal of co
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct sur sur rt france je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou